another legal headache for Donald Trump
he's become the first former American
president to face Federal criminal
charges less than three months after he
was indicted in New York for allegedly
falsifying business records Trump says
it's a hoax our country is going to hell
and they come after Donald Trump
weaponizing the justice department
weaponizing the FBI we can't let this
continue to go on because it's ripping
our country to shreds we have such big
problems and this shouldn't be one of
them he's facing seven counts related to
the mishandling of classified documents
at his Mar-A-Lago estate in Florida in
August last year Federal officials
seized dozens of boxes of files from his
home many of them classified but Trump
insists he's done nothing wrong and it's
just a continuation seven years even
after I'm out but it's called election
interference they're trying to destroy a
reputation so they can win an election
that's just as bad as doing any of the
other things that have been done over
the last number of years and especially
during the 2020 election and Republicans
have jumped to his defense including
some of his challenges for the
Republican nomination for next year's
presidential election but U.S President
Joe Biden has denied accusations of
political interference Mr President
Americans to convince them that they
should trust the independence and
fairness of the justice department with
your predecessor Donald Trump repeatedly
attacks it because you notice I have
never once not one single time
suggested adjustment of what they should
do or not do well to bring into charge
and not bring in charge I'm honest and
God bless America thank you very much
Trump says he summons to appear in
course in Miami on Tuesday but it's not
clear if he's planning to turn up and
even if the charges results in a
conviction that still won't prevent him
from running for president in 2024. Alex
beard Al Jazeera